hi everyone my name is Jerry chambers
and I'm Malcolm ray and this is Tara's
ever seen and I've never seen it today
we are watching a dud Walker is a
favorite film Brazil looking at you can
already kind of get a gist of what we're
in for it gives me a very strong Doug
vine yeah I think we're gonna be a
primarily just trying to decide if we
ourselves like it because right I mean
you can already kind of tell why this
might be a Doug Phil I I don't nothing
an Abbott though I've heard it talked
about in film school you know yeah I've
heard about you know Terry Gilliam and
okay he's a crazy imagination that's the
director yeah that's the directory looks
like he's good
Robert DeNiro in it property Nero
Jonathan Pryce who is the father of
Elizabeth Swann in parts of the
Caribbean I didn't put up predictions on
Twitter for this one because Doug
actually filmed some for us so we'll let
you know what we think that will show it
he thinks we're gonna think see if we
think he thought we were on three one
two three
[Music]
I don't even know where to start this
movie what no it makes sense this is
definitely a dub film movie I feel like
there was so much going on there's a lot
there I followed this story but there's
so much else going on just when you
think you've figured out what you think
is going on more questions just bubble
up to the surface
you're in this dystopian industrial sort
of I don't even know what to call it I
don't want to say cyberpunk with that I
know that's not right
why are you kind of very like Bioshock
feel it's set in a world where terrorism
is apparently just a regular thing I
mean I think I missed so much when we
had this subtitles on thank you I would
miss 50% more if I didn't have a
subtitles on I don't know what to feel
about it
me neither it was intriguing yeah it
kept my attention I I wanted to know
more I and that is a very good sign for
a film when you want to know more about
just trying to figure out the world was
its own like you can watch this so many
times and I feel like still you'll see
something new each time because there's
something going on in the background
like there's just like little details
there's ducks like these massive ducks
everywhere in every building wait and it
all has to do with information
information like that nothing yet yeah
right we really have to do
finishing heating and then information
passing the bare bones of the story is
that Sam Larry is in love with this
woman who he keeps having daydreams
about and in the midst of finding her he
gets caught up in a lot of like
bureaucratic trouble and like
misinterpreted identities and and like a
lot to get after this woman who he ends
up with in the end oh no he doesn't
yeah he doesn't yeah this is spoiler
short yeah yeah spoiler cuz it came out
in 1986 he has these daydreams about
this woman you know he sees himself it's
like the stalwart hero with wings you
know I just dreams he's flying around
fighting bad guys and he's constantly
pursuing this love of his life and one
day while he's going to work he sees her
image on one of the TV screens as TV
monitors and from then on he's just like
awestruck he's like oh my god this woman
actually exists in her alive and so the
story is him like trying to get to this
woman and figure out who she is and they
end up on a whirlwind adventure where
he's trying to protect her from the
organization but it ends up backfiring
it's the kind of scripts where it's
gonna always be relevant I think there
are always many aspects of of what's
happening in the film happening in your
life like government wise a lot of
things you can tell him just really been
influenced by this movie yeah I
definitely feel like Bioshock was
heavily influenced by this weird gory
cool parts too like the plastic surgery
like when the explosions would happen
really great effects I thought but I'm
glad you were here I feel like watching
this alone I would have just it's a lot
it's a lot to observe and just try to
process I we were here for each other
though okay but yeah you gotta talk to
each other throughout this film to make
sure
we were on a saint baby looking good I'm
not the only one that's completely so in
the very ends we were both just like
what's in the action it go it really
goes off the rails of the very he's
getting tortured and I guess his brain
just kind of checks out and he creates
this whole fantasy for himself
throughout the film he goes from
dreaming as like this wing into hero or
into like reality like no it's like half
and half what is happening we can't
really tell and then it turns out that
it was just a fantasy in his mind which
was really sad but I'm so glad that
that's how it went I'm so glad that it
wasn't just like this yes I was trying
to figure out why is this film named
Brazil all things and throughout the
movie like the song Brazil comes up
alive people are humming is playing in
the background
it's part of the film's theme the
composers said that he wanted to free
the Samba away from the tragedies of
life of the sensual scenario already so
explored so I guess it's speaking to
escapism I guess and that's kind of the
theme of this film it's like Sam's
constantly trying to escape from the
hardships of reality I also really want
to know what the budget was for like the
sets and the props they were all so
incredibly bad
yeah it's rooted like this stuff exists
in real life I'm just curious where they
were filming how much of it was built
how much of it was just on on location
and just really weird imagery to the
baby monsters yeah unlike the baby masks
that Jack wears when he's going in there
to torture him it was oddly solid yeah
yeah because it goes from dystopia and
then it starts feeling more like a noir
film
and it starts feeling like a
psychological it just screams dog walker
it really does I see it now yeah it
makes so much sense really
it makes so much things yeah it's such
an interesting thing to see dog walkers
favorite film because he's like the king
with movies in my mind you've seen every
film that we exactly feel like to see
his favorite is a very interesting look
into the life right okay these are my
predictions of Malcolm and Tamara are
watching my favorite movie of all time
Brazil you're gonna be confused like
most people are after watching it a
white guy what's after watching it trust
me it does make sense it's not like all
abstract and open to interpretation and
it actually does make sense but the
parts where you tuned out for a second
you're gonna wish you didn't - now for a
second why does and the parts where you
said oh maybe I should put the subtitles
on you're really good at which you put
the subtitles because they throw a lot
at you really fast I think you'll like
it
I don't think you'll love it I didn't
love it until I saw it a second time um
but I think you'll find it as being very
impressive and neat movie I don't know
if you'll like it as much as I like it
but I think it's pretty cool and I think
you'll find it pretty cool - yeah that
was pretty spot-on yeah I guess I liked
it I mean I don't like love it love it
yeah I definitely think I'll need to
give it some time before I have a second
viewing because there is so much going
on it's like we said that most it was
really watching but like oh there is so
much happening right now and
oopsies I guess terry gilliam but who
sees that scripting is like that's
something that I can bring so much you
have to be ambitious a to make that
happen so really doing okay
well less hair flip okay oh hell yeah
yeah
now if it was the hair flip King I'm a
channel American beep yeah yeah thank
you so much for joining me on this weird
but impressive adventure thank you for
having me thanks for watching everyone
I'll see you all next week
thank you yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
you